herzlichen wie auf einem kanal leute und
zwar nicht irgendein video sondern zu
einem sehr besonderen video ich weiß das
sag mal als motive aber das wie heute
wird wirklich besonders deswegen solltet
ihr auch unbedingt bis zum ende dran
bleiben ich verfolgte allem einen kanal
denke ich mal wissen was ich sonst
verkommt immobilie und dass ich mich in
der regel auf einem kanal über
irgendwelche us tv sendung lustig mache
aber ich bin heute mal ein bisschen was
persönlicheres machen ich will dass ihr
als meine zuschauer die ihr mich ja echt
schon relativ oft in der woche sieht
mich auch besser versteht
wisst ihr was ich meine ich will quasi
dass wir uns besser kennen lernen und zu
diesem zweck macht dieses video und
ähnliches video hat max auch schon mal
auf seinem kanal gemacht habe ich euch
verlinkt erster linker beschreibung
zirkus auf jeden fall auch auf und wir
sind dieses videos das andere ein kumpel
von mir zu vier freunden von mir
gegangen ist und jedem dieser vier
freunde sechs sehr persönliche fragen
über mich gestellt hat andrea das ganze
aufgenommen wie die aufnahmen zu
gespielt ich habe die aufnahmen bis
jetzt noch nicht gesehen wir werden
jetzt quasi live in diesem video
zusammen diese antworten anschauen ich
werde ein bisschen was über mich lernen
und ihr werdet sehr viel über mich
lernen denke ich und ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit der ersten frage wie lautet
wo siehst du mich in fünf jahren
ich glaube sie wird zum mega
geschäftsmann von irgendwas ich kann
mich irgendwie vorstellen ich weiß es
kreative tief in seinem herzen
schlummert aber ich kann mir vorstellen
dass der sohn richtigen business weg
noch geht es also das ist eine sache die
ich mir tatsächlich auch bei ein paar
leuten schon als antwort hätte
vorstellen können weil ich ja auch ein
studium in wirtschaftswissenschaften
gemacht habe und ich auch viel mit
meinen leuten so darüber reden dass ich
viel spaß in dem studium gehabt habe und
dass ich mir auch spaß daran haben mit
zahlen zu arbeiten und so ja wer weiß
aber interessant sebastian wird in fünf
jahren auf jeden fall ein größeres auto
fahren als 17
[Musik]
noch größer und ich glaube der ich kann
mir so richtig vorstellen dass sebastian
so überraschen der typ ist ja einfach in
einem jahr sagt ich verkündete familie
und dann hat er in vier in fünf jahren
jährige tochter am dreijährigen sohn
kreis alter also ich muss sagen wenn ich
jetzt darüber nachdenken das thema
family so ist natürlich was ich also was
ist natürlich ist ja nicht bei jedem
sommer das ist was was ich auf jeden
fall will worauf ich auch bock habe aber
als ich habe es jetzt noch nicht so auf
dem schirm für die nächsten jahre muss
ich sagen
vielleicht überrascht mich selbst damit
vor das ist schwierig weil ich sehe bei
dem mehrere optionen zum einen kann ich
mir schon vorstellen dass du einfach
weiter hassels auf youtube und so aber
eigentlich kann ich mir fast besser
vorstellen dass wir nochmal so den
anderen weg geht wie bisher auch stark
was einfach keine ahnung so
wirtschaftlich und auch so dass normales
studium angeht also ich kann mich
eigentlich auch beim einstieg in
klassischen beruf vorstellen kann vor
allem sehr gut vorstellen dass du gut
karriere machen könntest ja leute das
ist tatsächlich ein gedanke den ich auch
schon ab und zu mal habe muss ich sagen
so bei youtube ist so alles cool und so
aber ich habe oftmals das gefühl dass
ich hätte viel mehr machen könnte als
nur youtube versteht ihr was ich meine
also irgendwas machen wo ich ein
bisschen mehr so die fähigkeiten ich
habe besser einsetzen kann versteht was
ich meine ich glaube es gibt so ein
bisschen in die richtung aber auf jeden
fall das so erfolgreich sein das mit dem
was du machst
wo sich in fünf jahren ich wünsche dir
dass ich dich nicht mehr auf youtube
sehen dass wir jetzt erstmal komisch an
aber ich glaube dass dein platz und da
wo du eigentlich hin willst nicht auf
youtube ist sondern irgendwie in einer
großen firma mit einer wichtigen
position oder sogar in der politik ich
glaube du interessierst dich sehr viel
tiefer gehende themen und ich sehe dich
in fünf jahren mit einer abgeschlossenen
masterstudium weil du schon seit ich
dich kenne davon gehen ist dass du gerne
sein master anfangen willst ja das
stimmt heute tatsächlich also es ist wie
gesagt jetzt kann eben schon bei baumax
glaube ich angesprochen dass ich
manchmal das gefühl habe dass ich mich
nicht so richtig fordert zu und ich sehe
die leute mit denen ich meinen bachelor
an der uni gemacht hat pressen sehr
schlaue intelligente leute die mich auch
inspirieren oftmals und die machen jetzt
im master und so und gehen noch weiter
und lernen weiter dann habe ich manchmal
auch lust so auch in diese richtung zu
gehen versteht ja ich will irgendwie was
machen was mich mehr einnimmt was mich
mehr fordert und auch post als nur
youtube zum beispiel rückegassen allein
für die erste frage jetzt schon elf
monate aufgenommen das muss müssen
schneller machen zweite frage wie
erfolgreich bin ich bei frau lassen wir
den girls mal den vortritt
ich glaube wenn dann steht dass ich nur
selbst im weg aber so von eins bis zehn
würde ich ihm schon so ne achtgeben ok
ok ja ich kann ich kann ein bisschen
verstehen was kelly man die sache ist
krass auf das ist so ein thema meinen
youtube berührt das ist wirklich ein
ganz anderes wir heute voll krass also
die sache ist glaube ich das so gerade
beim thema dating und so andere leute
kennenlernen es ist so dass raps gefühls
kommt nur darauf an so möglichst
penetrant zu sein sohn einfach nur leute
zu belagern bis irgendwann dieser
und das hat nicht so mein stil ich bin
ja so ein bisschen ich bin in der
umgebung von den richtigen leuten sehr
sehr extrovertiert aber wenn ich neue
leute kennenlerne oftmals ein bisschen
introvertierter und deswegen ja ich
glaube dass das was kelly meint mit sich
selbst im weg stehen gut aber auch das
gut neun habe ich also alleine vom
erfolgs als ich da wenn er seine bilder
bitte die auch oder auch nicht doch ich
hab schon okay ja also es war auf jeden
fall nicht immer in meinem leben so dass
ich jedes mädchen bekommen aber an dem
ich interesse hat das nicht weil ich
meine das ist glaube ich auch noch mal
habe ich mich bisher entwickelt ich war
früher mit 15 weiter aus ein bisschen
weniger selbstbewusst und auch einfach
nicht klagen jetzt nicht sportlich oder
sowas und hab ich die ganze runde selbst
gefühlt jetzt ist das schon deutlich
besser bei mir das ist glaube ich auch
ein faktor damit spielt deswegen ist
jetzt besser läuft in front also sicher
dass du gut auf frauen gehört dass
frauen nicht attraktiv finden und gut
aussehend erfolg bei frauen sieht für
mich auf jeden fall nicht nur aus dass
man halt viele frauen hat sondern dass
man halt auch die frau hat so die einem
wirklich was bedeutet in der hinsicht
wünsche ich dir auf jeden fall dass du
da auch noch jemanden findet aber
allgemein ist es glaube ich kein
geheimnis das so gut ankommt bei frauen
aber ich wünsche dir auf jeden fall eine
topzeit
ja das stimmt tatsächlich also eine live
lassen von mir ist auf jeden fall
es ist tatsächlich auf jeden fall
deutlich erfülle eine einzelne person
oder mit einer einzelperson zu sein
damit der mehr in die tiefe zu gehen und
einander besser zu verstehen einander
aufzubauen als kanal viele wechselnde
bekanntschaften zu haben kurzfristiger
erfolg für kürzere bekanntschaften bist
du extrem erfolgreich was langfristige
beziehungen angeht habe ich das gefühl
dass du damit so ein bisschen deine
probleme hast dadurch hast du dir
wahrscheinlich auch schon das ein oder
andere mal das leben ein bisschen
schwerer gemacht als das eigentlich
hättest machen müssen krassesten von
dave also ich glaube dieser schritt mit
irgendeiner person irgendwie irgendwas
was tiefer das rein zu gehen ist aber
auch nicht leicht das fällt manchen
leuten mit sicherheit auch aufgrund
ihrer vergangenheit
schwerer als anderen leuten und manche
können sich da sofort rein stützen sind
von anfang an so wie auch alles andere
ich vertraue dir und andere haben da
brauchen eine viel längere aufwärtsphase
aber das wird noch leute das wird die
frage noch mal dran also interessiert
mich auch richtig krass was ist meine
größte stärke
ich glaube seine konstant ausstrahlung
ich glaube damit kanal viele menschen
von was überzeugen würde ich jetzt mal
sagen okay kraska ist das hätte ich
jetzt gar nicht so erwartet muss ich
sagen als antwort natürlich ist damit zu
sagen dass ich mich selbst so von außen
die wahrnehme und gar nicht einschätzen
können wie ich so auf andere wirke ja
ich höre dass tatsächlich oft dass ich
so nach außen zu wirken aber ich bin auf
jeden fall ein mensch der sich gedanken
viele sachen macht vielleicht auch in
manchen bereichen mehr als andere oder
sehr sicher mehr als andere
das ist interessant das zusammenspiel
eigentlich so wie man so nach innen und
sich selbst denken wie man so nach außen
wirkt ich glaube dass viele leute
sebastian manchmal unterschätzen
in vielen dingen und dass das so seine
größte stärke ist weil er kann voll viel
der hat voll viel im kopf so und der ja
der hat mehr drauf als man denkt so auf
den ersten blick vielleicht interessant
ok also ich könnte mir vorstellen das
was sie damit meint so ist dass das
spiel ein bisschen mit ihm zusammen es
entstand gesagt habe dass es die ganzen
leute nicht vielleicht auch
eingeschlossen nicht sogar ganz leicht
fällt so direkt von anfang wenn man
irgendwann kennen also ganz offen zu
sein und da gibt man sich vielleicht in
so eine art und weise da verhält sich
eine art und weise die nicht 1000
prozent oder nur zum kleinen teil das
widerspiegelt was man wirklich ist und
das was man eigentlich ist würde
vielleicht viel besser ankommen als ich
mir vorstelle natürlich so was macht ich
würde sagen deine größte stärke ist die
tatsache dass du die sachen vornehmen
kannst durchziehen kannst und
selbstbewusst bei der sache ist dass
wirklich starken dass auch eine
eigenschaften wichtig ein bisschen
beneidet
voll krass alter und wenn sie voll oft
eigentlich auch mehr so zu anderen
leuten und denken so
ich finds bei den kassen was diese
durchziehen und ich finde es bei mir
selbst vor
juli wenn ich irgendwie dann reicht das
gefühl dass ich voll oft sachen mir
vornehmen und nicht so ganz richtig ist
die daraus wo sie werden zeugen jack ich
glaube deine größte stärke ist gegen
dich selber anzugehen und sich selber
aus dem komfort sorgen zu pushen
du bist der einzige von uns der den
sport langfristig durchzieht und sich
langfristig irgendwie aus der
komfortzone bewegen kann und zum sport
gehen oder das lässt sich auf alles
beziehen ich weiß nicht du bist bereit
scheiße zu fressen um langfristig erfolg
zu haben das finde ich sehr
bewundernswert und dann bist du aus
unserem engsten kreis definitiv der bei
dem es am stärksten ausgeprägt ist
heftig leute wieder das geld eben schon
zu dem was max gesagt hat ich habe so
das gefühl ich kann habe ich vergleiche
nicht immer so mit leuten die halt da
noch die ja viel besser sind als ich und
keine leute die jetzt beim sportfest
wenn ich vier mal oder dreimal die woche
sport mache dann vergleich mit leuten
die sie mal die woche sport mache denkt
ihr sowie das wissen von julie alt also
machen ein bisschen mehr aber wenn ich
jetzt drei videos die woche hochladen
und dann schaue ich mir leute an die 7
wird die woche wohl alle denken wir dass
immer noch nicht genug was du machst
aber ich kann es auf jeden fall
verstehen was dave meint also ich bin
nicht so dass sich immer alles im moment
genau selbst gut anfühlen muss man ein
stück weit kann ich schon aber ich würde
es gerne noch besser können fragen ob
hier was ist meine größte schwäche
jetzt gibt es auch eine decke was ich
dann eben auch schon als seine größte
stärke gelernt habe das finde ich ein
stück weit auch deine größte schwäche
das manchmal zu sehr
dein eigenes ding durchziehen sich ein
bisschen abkoppelt und ja so also deine
eigene schiene fährt und ich halt da
nicht so sehr auf andere einlässt das
ist eine sache die schon zutrifft die ja
ein paar mal vom von von leuten gehört
habe ich habe einfach glaube ich einen
sehr eigenen kauf von der klare
vorstellung von dem was ich so machen
will und was nicht und wenn ich das dann
nicht machen kann dann fällt mir das in
der regel relativ schwer und ich fühle
mich dann voll schon leben wie eingeengt
immer so
und das kann denn ich es kranke einfach
nicht da wird wohl auch was dran sein
leute ich glaube spiel bisschen mit dem
zusammen was max kade eben schon meinte
nämlich dass ich so meinen eigenen kopf
habe ich glaube ich müsste ein bisschen
mehr meine pläne oder das was ich mache
an den dingen um mich herum und den
menschen um mich herum orientieren also
quasi die die meine umweltbedingungen
und die menschen um mich herum bisschen
mehr an das rein beziehen wie ich plane
oder überhaupt erst mal planen ja deine
größte schwäche ist es dass du in
manchen situationen bei denen zum
kurzschlussreaktionen jetzt meistens
geht das ist dir da ein bisschen an
selbstreflexion fehlt langfristig
reflektiert du meistens sehr gut selber
aber wenn die reaktion sonne so eine
kurzschlussreaktion ist dann ist es
häufig nicht so stimmig irgendwie ja ich
das kann man glaube ich auch ein stück
weit schon nachvollziehen dass ich kein
ist ein stück weit nachvollziehen so
dieses ding das man kann aber im moment
aber wenn man neben diskussionen ist
oder so was viele sachen vielleicht zu
oft auch persönlich nimmt zu sehr auf
sich selbst bezieht und sich dann in so
einer verteidigungsposition gibt und
dann denkt okay ich würde jetzt
angegriffen ich muss jetzt zurückfordern
daraus entsteht dann halt in der regel
darauf folgend nichts gutes sondern eher
so eine konfliktsituation als dass man
das irgendwie auflöst ist es sebastian
ist sie machen das immer zu spät ist er
braucht immer fast so lange das ist
absolut sei der größte schwäche ja ja ja
ja wenn du bist so trödler vor dem herrn
es hat halt ein bisschen organisierter
werden bisschen mehr manche sachen
durchziehen also zum beispiel als kelly
hat bei der aufnahme auf ewig auf mich
gewartet vielen dank dafür nochmal kelly
ja ich habe so ein bisschen in meinem
kopf meine eigene zeitrechnung die
möglicherweise nicht immer mit der der
restlichen welt übereinstimmt frage 4
ganz ein bisschen was auf deckel jetzt
kommt frage 5 vielleicht gibt es ja ein
bisschen mehr positives zu berichten
die frage lautet wie attraktiv würdest
du mich einschätzen
mal schauen also ich glaube du bist sehr
attraktiv was das allgemeine will
angeht also ist groß bist sportlich wenn
sie jetzt um meinen typ gehen würde
würde ich sagen dass du weniger
attraktiv bist einfach wald um vom
aussehen her nicht mein typ bist aber
all in all ist ein sehr attraktiver
junger mann
ok also mit der wird schon mal nix leute
chance leider alle die fashion's von dem
er geschrieben haben zumindest in
realität wird es eigentlich passiert
aber okay also ich glaube so für die
allgemeinheit so was hat man somit
bekommt ist sebastian schramm so eine
stabile 9
oder vielleicht sogar eine stabile 10
ich glaube es gibt keinen menschen der
jemals sebastian gesehen und mich gesagt
hat okay der sieht gut aus der ist
attraktiv also wenn ich jetzt von mir
aus rechts dazu meint ist würde ich
sagen auch so schon so eine art oder
sieben mal
ich muss dazu sagen würde also die
fragen so ausgeschrieben hatte mein
handy notiz mir diese durchgelesen habe
habe ich teilweise gedacht so kommt dass
wir ein bisschen komisch rüber wenn man
so was fragt aber einfach um die
kontinuität zu haben habe das gemacht
weil max ist auch in seinem video
gemacht hat und man braucht ja auch
maxis video auch er ist ja nicht mehr
über steuerung wie gesagt und ja genau
das stellt auch gleich etwas hand so
weil sowas darüber redet man eigentlich
auch nicht erst recht nicht unter
freunden normalerweise glaube auch dass
ich so von bekommen diese bastion
gesehen haben waren 259 okay leute also
bisher ganz gut weggekommen muss man
sagen ein like mal gucken was magst dazu
sagt ich würde dir einen neuen geben auf
einer skala von 1 bis 10
der eine punkt fehlt nicht ich biss
[Gelächter]
mitbewerber fraktion komplett legal
wachsen also nicht dass irgendeiner
falsch versteht magst du bist der letzte
mensch also das ernst meinen würde also
noch heute jetzt gehen wir zur letzten
frage zu frage noch mal sechs und die
wird noch mal richtig richtig
interessant denn dadurch leute gefragt
was würdest du mir raten plötzlich das
sei immer sein herz folgen sollen sich
von nichts ablenken lassen soll von
irgendwelchen anderen aspekten und was
er mal mehr seinem bauchgefühl als
seinem kopf vertrauen soll war ich
glaube das was ja alles schon vielen
kopf stecken aber das stimmt ja also
fällt phasenweise durchaus schwer so aus
dem bauch entscheidung zu treffen muss
das stimmt ja also ich bin echt so
jemand der mit dem kopf son trifft ein
master studium anzufangen
auf youtube das umzusetzen was du
wirklich willst und seine pläne
umzusetzen weiter an dir selber zu
arbeiten was diese selbstreflexion in
kurzschlussreaktionen angeht und wir
haben in den letzten tagen unfassbar
gute tiefgründige gespräche gehabt kurs
ist ein cooles video a interessante
radja dass auf jeden fall wichtig leute
dass man so an sein seinen schwächen
arbeitet und auch sowas kontakt mit
anderen leuten angeht das stimmt ja also
ich habe ein bisschen wehmut dass ich
ein bisschen was für andere bestimmt
mehr im hier und jetzt zu leben und
mitbekommen was er macht weil ich habe
manchmal das gefühl dass er ganz viel
will und immer weiter will und gar nicht
dann so realisiert was ja gerade so tut
als wir auch im urlaub fahren hat er
gesagt er will mehr videos machen und
wie ist das das und dabei macht er schon
relativ viele videos für so den meisten
leute die ich kenne die videos machen
ich glaube manchmal manchmal bilder zu
weit hinauf und sieht nicht dass er
schon echt krank viel erreicht hat und
echt viel auch dafür tut und das er
verdient hat das ist ja ja keine ahnung
also manchen punkten bin ich auf jeden
fall so ein bisschen so
getrieben also so dass man nicht so
wirklich drauf schauen kann was man
schon bisher gemacht hat sondern hat
immer weiter nach oben vergleicht und so
und das ist auch völlig gesund ich weiß
das würde ich auch keinem empfehlen aber
das halt so ist dann in einem drin fed
bisschen öfter mal ein bisschen mehr so
im moment ankommen und einfach mal ein
bisschen chillen checken haus gerade
abgeht und ich schon mit den gedanken
drei wochen voraus oder in der
vergangenheit oder sonst wo sollen die
allgemeinen mehr zu öffnen
gar nicht mal so sehr eine richtung aber
vielleicht einfach für neue inhalte auf
youtube im allgemeinen für neue menschen
einfach offen durchs leben gehen ja das
war lieb aber ja das was dran heute max
kennt mich natürlich sehr gut und ich
glaube wie gesagt das hat viel damit zu
tun ob man in seinem leben schon mal
durch harte phase gegangen ist und wenn
man das hatte und wirklich meine ein
paar jahre wirklich heftige phase hatte
wo es einen sehr schlecht ging fährt man
einfach bauernhof und die dann wieder
runter zu fallen irgendwann später im
leben ist glaube ich echt ein hartes
stück arbeit ist es nichts was von
selbst kommt ja leute krasses video sehr
sehr lieb ist video ich hoffe und ich
denke irgendwo dass es bei euch auch gut
ankommen wird weil ich glaube solche
momente von ok irgendjemand zeigt mal
wirklich wer ist und kein bisschen aus
diesem dieser youtuber rolle raus ich
glaube das würde ich mir wünschen ich
glaube ihr habt da wahrscheinlich auch
spaß daran gehabt schreibt eure gedanken
und in die kommentare schreibt unten
rein bei welchen dingen in diesem video
ihr vielleicht irgend bezug zu euch
selbst herstellen könnte und wie das für
euch so ist ihr kriegt hier einfach
vorgeschlagen das video hier oben könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren ja das was die
leute von mir die augen macht's gut